DAVID GAGEOT: Thank you,
everybody, for being here.
How did you like
the sessions before?
Was it good?
Yeah?
No?
OK, we're going to try
to make just one good.
So we're going to talk about
this code and Kubernetes.
But before I do that,
let me introduce myself.
I'm David Gageot.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Cloud Platform.
I'm based out of
Paris, and I love
everything that's related
to developer experience.
And I love cats, and there's
no connection between the two.
You can find me on
Twitter and GitHub.
So what is it like to be a
developer in the Kubernetes
world?
Are there any developers
here in the room--
yeah-- deploying to Kubernetes?
Yeah?
How do you like it?
Who doesn't like it?
Most of the people like
it because my opinion is
that it's a mess, like the house
is on fire, and everybody says,
yeah, it's fine.
There's billions of
tools, billions of layers,
lots of complexity.
But you don't have to trust me.
We asked our users
what they think
about how hard it is to develop
applications for Kubernetes,
and they found it frustrating.
They say that there's
too much configuration.
They say that
debugging is a pain.
When you're used to
debugging inside your IDE,
debugging for something that's
deployed on Kubernetes cluster
is very complicated.
They say that applications
have too many moving parts,
and basically they want to
spend more time on their code.
Who wants to spend more
time on their code?
I do.
So today for Next we
introduce Cloud Code.
Cloud Code is a set of
extensions for IntelliJ and VS
Code, and it will help
you as a developer
to get more productive
and focus on your code
and just work on your code,
edit your applications,
deploy them continuously
to a cluster.
Who wants to see that in action?
Yeah?
OK.
So let's do the demo.
Oops.
Let's do the demo.
So I'm going to start
by starting VS Code.
So in VS Code--
OK, so you don't see it.
Can you see it now?
On the bar on the left,
there is a new icon, which
is the Cloud Code extension.
If I click on it, I can
see all the clusters
that I have access to.
And right now what I
have is Docker Desktop
which gives me a Kubernetes
cluster on my local machine.
And I can browse what's
deployed on my cluster,
and I can see that I
have no deployments.
I've got maybe a few pods.
There's one pod that's
running one container.
And you can see here in
action already that Cloud Code
makes you very productive.
You don't have to use a CLI to
browse what you're deploying
on cluster, and you can connect
to a container and stream
the logs.
Hey, local Next.
We see the logs that
are from that container.
We can also maybe go
inside one of the container
and get a terminal.
Yeah, I've got a terminal,
and I'm inside a container.
It's running on the cluster.
Whether it's local or
remote, I don't care.
It's quite easy.
You can do the same thing
with the kubectl CLI.
But from your IDE, it's
more comfortable, right?
Right now I've got
only one cluster,
and I'm going to want to
deploy it on the cloud.
And because it's Google Cloud,
I'm going to deploy it on GKE,
but in fact Cloud Code makes it
possible to create from my IDE
a cluster on any cloud provider.
I can create a cluster
on AWS, on Azure.
I can create, of
course, a GK cluster.
So for my demo, I'm going to
click on Create GK Cluster,
and inside my IDE, I'm going
to have a very simplified
version of the Cluster
Creation Wizard
that helps me create a
cluster for my development.
So I'm going to use
the default project ID.
I'm going to choose
one of the zones.
I'm going to put, I don't
know, this one maybe,
and I'm going to give
a name to my cluster.
And that's it.
I'm going to create the cluster.
It's going to take
a few minutes.
In the background, it's
going to create the cluster,
and when it's done,
it's going to appear
in the bottom-left
section here where
I can see all my
clusters on the cloud.
So I've got a cluster
that's going to be created.
I want to work on some code, but
I don't really know how to get
started.
I'm a little new to Kubernetes.
So I'm going to use
one of the features
from Cloud Code
which is very useful,
which is the new
application creation.
With Cloud Code, we are
shipping code samples
that you can use to learn
Kubernetes platform, to learn
to code applications with
your favorite language
for Kubernetes.
So you have the choice between
Python, Go, Node.js, Java,
.Net, and you have simple
or more complicated samples.
It's a good way to get started,
and I'm going to choose one.
I'm going to choose
the Go hello world.
So it's going to
clone that project.
It's going to open a new
window with that project,
and it's a fully
configured project.
Very easy, but that
helps me to get started.
It's a typical Go application,
so I can see the sources here.
There is a CMD package,
and there's a main.go.
It's basically going to run
a web server on port 8080,
and it's going to
say hello world.
Very simple.
But there's also a Docker
file to containerize
that application.
It's already created for me.
There's what's needed to
compile the application
but also what's
needed to debug it.
And there's also a few
Kubernetes manifests
that I can learn from to
learn about Kubernetes.
What's interesting here is that
I can hover on any keyword,
and I have the
full documentation
from the Kubernetes manifest.
So I can really
start to understand
what each configuration means,
and it's really very useful.
And I also have validation.
For example, here it's
waiting for an integer,
so I cannot type
this type of value.
Here I've got a service.
And for example, for
the type I can have--
oops.
I have completion.
That-- no.
Yeah.
Come on.
I don't know what's going on.
Demo effect.
Usually I have completion.
So it really helps
me to get started.
So now I want to deploy that
application on Docker Desktop.
And you'd expect to run
some kind of command
chain like docker build,
docker push, kubectl apply,
but you don't really
want to do that.
You're inside your IDE.
You want to focus on your code.
So you're going to use
Cloud Code to deploy
your application.
You're going to choose Deploy.
And Deploy will do everything
I said for you automatically.
I'm going to deploy it
with the G4 profile.
I'm going to deploy
it on Docker Desktop.
So it's going to
build the image.
It's going to tag the image.
It's going to put the
image name in the YAML,
and it's going to
send it to Kubernetes.
And when it's done,
it's going to give me
the URL that I can connect to
and see that it's deployed,
you see?
So it's really easy.
I can just focus on my code.
I can learn Kubernetes.
And I say deploy to Cloud
Code, and boom, it's deployed.
Do you find it nice?
Is it good?
Is it good already?
So it's really here
to help you get
started because a lot of
people don't know the platform.
There's so many layers,
so many commands
that you have to learn.
It's easier if the
IDE does it for you.
What did I want to say?
So all of this is possible
because Cloud Code
is using a product underneath
that's called Skaffold.
And Skaffold has a configuration
file which you can see here.
You don't have to learn
that configuration
file because Cloud Code will
do it for you most of the time,
but basically what it says is
all the images I want to build,
all the artifacts
I want to deploy,
which tool is going
to be used to deploy,
whether it's kubectl or Helm.
You can have profiles,
et cetera, et cetera.
You can say how the images
are going to be tagged.
And once this
configuration is there,
you don't have to
think about it.
And it's there already
for all the samples.
So you can just type
cloud run deploy,
and it's going to be deployed.
I've got a more
complicated project
that I want to work on,
which is a guestbook.
But this one is not finished.
It's not a sample.
It's just work in progress.
So work in progress--
so what can I say
about this project?
So it's Node.js now,
and I've got a back end
with an entry point.
I've got a Docker file
that I've created also.
I've got a front-end entry
point and a Docker file.
And I started already to type
some of Kubernetes manifest.
Somebody gave them to me.
And there is one deployment
to deploy, MongoDB,
and there is a secret that
gives a username and password
to database and that
my back end should
use to connect to the back end.
By the way, you can see that
here Cloud Code is also here
to help you by giving you
tools to decode base64 username
and password, for example.
It's very convenient.
But I need more
YAML files, right,
because Kubernetes is
about YAML files, right?
So I'm going to do one
YAML file for my back end.
Back end, OK.
The good old white page.
What should I type?
Can you help me?
It's very complicated.
So Cloud Code is here to have.
So with Cloud Code--
oh, my completion is--
OK.
Cloud Code is going to help
me type a typical deployment.
I'm going to say deployment, OK.
Deployment-- it's going
to be the back end.
I need to choose an image name.
I'm going to just
call it back end.
And that I don't know.
So of course, you still have to
understand what you're typing,
but Cloud Code is here to help.
Same for the service.
You don't have to
type or copy-paste.
You just use that
and start from here.
And I know that the
Node application
is running on port 9000.
Should be good.
This was very quick, right?
I'm going to do the same
thing for the service--
for the front end, sorry.
Front end-- so I'm going
to have a deployment.
I'm going to change
the image name.
I don't know what I'm going
to put there, but front end.
And I'm going to add a service.
So this time my service needs
to be exposed to the outside.
So it's going to
be a load balancer.
So I'm going to type service.
Give it a name.
Oops.
And I'm going to
choose load balancer.
Yeah, load balancer, completion.
So I've got all the
types that I can use.
And I know this is load
balancer that I want.
And I can check
the documentation.
And yes, that's
exactly what I want.
So this was quite quick.
No more copy-pasting.
It's not perfect.
We want to improve
that in the future,
but already it helps
you get started.
It helps you when you
have a blank page.
It's not really a
great experience,
and this time it's much better.
So I'm going to deploy
that to my cluster, right?
So Cloud Code deploy.
OK, there's a
problem because I've
got Docker files and
manifest, but it's
not enough for Cloud
Code to understand
what I want to deploy.
Which Docker file is
building which image,
and which image is used in
which Kubernetes manifest?
So that was the point of the
Skaffold YAML I showed you.
And I don't want to
type that, so I'm
going to let Cloud Code
help me to type that.
Do you want to
create a new profile?
Yes.
So basically all I have to do is
I've got the image names that's
Cloud Code found
in my YAML files,
and here there's
the Docker files.
And I just need to make pairs.
So that's quite easy, right?
The back-end Docker file
is for the back end.
Front end is for front end.
And Mongo is just
an image that's
going to be pulled
from the Docker hub.
So I'm going to save that
and proceed to deploy.
There's a lot of options that
I could tweak with the UI,
but I just want it to be
deployed as quick as possible.
So it's going to be deployed.
Ooh, there's a problem.
There's a problem.
It looks like my code is relying
on some environment variable.
So I told you that it's
going to connect to MongoDB.
It needs a username and
password to connect to MongoDB.
So I'm going to use the
values that are in the secret,
and I'm going to use them in
the back end YAML configuration.
But before I do that,
let me introduce you
to a new mode of deployment
that you have in Cloud Code.
It's called
continuous deployment.
When I do continuously
deploy, what it's going to do,
it's going to deploy
my application.
But each time I change
something like config file
or the sources, it's
going to rebuild what
needs to be rebuilt.
It's going to redeploy
what needs to be redeployed.
I just need to focus on my code.
That's it.
No more deploying.
It's going to be
done automatically.
So I can just fix my issue.
OK, MongoDB, username.
It needs environment variable.
So I'm going to
configure it here.
I'm going to add
environment variable.
It needs a name.
I'm going to use the
value from the secret.
So it's going to be a secret.
And Cloud Code, we even
complete the name of the secret
that I have in my project.
So I don't have to type them,
and I don't have to copy-paste.
OK, MongoDB, and it's
going to be the user name.
I can just save,
and boom, Cloud Code
will try to redeploy my
application in the background.
It's very quick.
And now it's complaining
about the password.
OK, let's do the password.
But you get the point.
You can really focus
on fixing your code,
and you can let Cloud
Code do the rest.
Completion is going
to be the password.
By the way, if I right
click here on mongo-secret,
it will show me the secret
in the other YAML file.
It will even show me the version
that's already deployed--
whoops, sorry--
already deployed in production.
Let me do that again.
Sorry.
Here, this is the version
that's deployed on the cluster.
So that's really super useful.
I can start to connect the
pieces together and start
to understand the links between
all those manifests and all
those objects.
So I'm going to
save that, and I'm
going to let Cloud Code deploy
it automatically for me.
And when it's done, it's
going to give me an endpoint.
Cross your finger.
Yeah, guestbook.
That was quite easy.
I didn't copy-paste anything.
I did not run any
chain of commands.
It's deployed on my cluster.
That's nice, right?
So I can use it.
I can use my app.
Hello Next.
And you can see it working,
but there is a bug here.
There is a bug.
So when there is a
bug, we need to debug.
So we're going to try to
debug that application.
But I will say that debugging
applications on Kubernetes
was very complicated because
it's not running locally
on my machine.
It's running on a cluster
somewhere on a pod.
It's quite complicated.
But with Cloud Code, it
doesn't have to be complicated.
I'm going to switch
to the Debug tab.
I'm going to debug the back end.
And it's going to connect
to my application.
It's running on the
pod, on a container,
but it doesn't matter.
It can connect to it.
It can debug it from VS Code
as any other application.
I'm going to put the breakpoint
somewhere that I know--
OK, this one.
I'm going to just refresh.
Where is it?
And boom-- OK, I'm debugging.
I've got a full debugger.
I can debug.
I've got a console.
I can print values, anything.
I can jump to the
next breakpoint,
and I can see that it's sending
a message with a name, a body.
And oh, there's a typo here.
It must be my bug.
I'm going to fix that.
I'm going to save it.
And boom, Cloud Code
is already redeploying
everything in production.
And it's already
deployed, and it's
hitting the breakpoint again.
And yeah, it worked.
So it's actually easy to debug
an application with Cloud Code.
You don't have to know
where it's running.
It's very easy to do.
It was just one click.
I've got three minutes.
So I told you I would
deploy it on Kubernetes.
Where is my cluster?
OK, so loading.
So yeah, there's a cluster here.
So I'm going to deploy
to that cluster.
So how do I do that?
I just ask Cloud Code to deploy.
I'm going to do
deploy, but this time--
oh, sorry.
I'm going to stop that.
I'm going to deploy.
Yes.
Oh, no, sorry, too quick.
I'm going to deploy,
but this time I'm
going to add a profile.
I'm not going to deploy in
my development environment
locally.
I'm going to deploy to
a new cluster, which
is my demo cluster.
But for that, I
need a new profile,
like development, production,
staging, whatever.
You can add as many
profiles as you want.
So I'm going to add a profile.
I'm going to call it Production.
And I could tweak the way the
images are built for production
or the way that images are
deployed for production,
but let's keep it this
way and do the same thing
but with a different cluster.
So I'm going to
proceed with deployment
and going to give
production in here.
Cloud Code is asking
me in which cluster
I want to deploy when I deploy
to production because it's
the first time I deploy
with that profile.
So I'm going to switch
to demo cluster.
And because then my images
needs to be pushed to a registry
because I'm deploying
to a remote cluster,
Cloud Code knows that and helps
me find out a good image name
to deploy my--
a good registry to
deploy my images.
So gc.io, yes, I'm
going to do that.
And now Cloud Code
will do the same thing,
like build my energy, tag my
images, send the YAML files,
but this time it's going
to target my remote closer.
And when it's done,
it's going to give me
a endpoint that
I can connect to.
We can maybe switch
to that cluster
and see how it is going.
So we're going to see
that we have deployments.
We can stream the
logs, see how it goes.
So it's basically
container creating.
So it's putting the image.
It takes some time to
start the container,
but in a few seconds,
it should be started.
So let's leave it this way.
And what we've seen
is that it's very easy
to deploy your
applications continuously
whether it's on a local
cluster or a remote cluster
with only the Cloud
Code Deploy command.
Cloud Code will help
you all the way.
And when you have to type
YAML when you have to debug,
Cloud Code is here to help.
So I told you it
would be deployed.
Let's try it.
Yeah, guestbook.
I'm on GKE.
So that's about it, what I
wanted to show you Cloud Code.
Let me switch back
to the slides.
So how can you get it?
You can get it on Visual Studio
Code, on the marketplace.
You can get it on IntelliJ
with the JerBrains Plugins
Repository, or you can go
to cloud.google.com/code.
You can use the QR code.
And we're going to announce
it's officially tomorrow.
And if you want to know more,
we have two other sessions
that you should attend.
So there is the Super-Charge
Your GKE Development Workflow
in VS Code and
IntelliJ, and there
is the Dead Easy Kubernetes
Workflows with VS Code.
And those two talks
would give you
more details about Cloud Code.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]